now I did a countdown a long time ago
called the top 11 audience and a maniac
moments and to this day it continues to
be the most viewed nostalgia critic
video and looking over these jokes again
I gotta say how did you get away with
half of these risque jokes I mean
they're just unbelievable you know I
don't know I don't know how we got away
with them I don't know I have no idea
how a lot of it is the benign neglect
III did see that segment of the
nostalgia critic and I loved it
the one from it's on the boat it's
something about finding fingerprints no
no no fingerprints our bold fun I mean
we obviously we put that in and we don't
we just said oh let the let the sensor
have a laugh and call us and I guess the
sensor was away that week because that's
still in there it's amazing
probably one of my favorite exchanges
where you know Yakko sings all the all
the planets Babylon to Neptune that
sigasi crazy ball and cold and tiny
Bluto it's the furthest one of all there
you go that's our solar system you
forgot your anus good night everybody
I think I put that in as a joke and
expecting Tom or someone in authority
with good taste to cut it out and they
never did so but then again you know Tom
wrote Lake Titicaca let me sing that for
you Lake Titicaca
thank you it was all double entendre so
it was uh it was more naughty than
anything I think you know we weren't
being we were trying not to be really
mean but we were being uh sort of
naughty you know you couldn't do it
today but what we did it that the our
gatekeeper our gatekeeper was pretty
much as twisted as we were so I think
that's the problem you should be ashamed
of yourself for even thinking it now
something I hear writers do a lot
especially on kids shows to get around
the censors is that they'll have a joke
that's a little risque and they think
the censors are going to pull off so
they put in an even bigger joke
something really shocking and really
risque to distract from the smaller risk
a joke did you guys ever do anything
like that that's exactly right and and
so you fight like mad for this really
outrageous thing that you know should
never be in there you fight fight fight
for that so that when the other thing
they they're so exhausted they say okay
you can have the other thing you guys
pretty much satirized well everything
you did movies eat it shows you did
music videos people did anyone ever get
upset at the jokes you made Tim Robbins
really we had won the Emmy the Daytime
Emmy and we were coming out and there
and Tim Robbins was escorting mr. Rogers
under the stage and as he passed us we
were walking he said I love you I love
Animaniacs but please don't please don't
ever put me in your curtain don't don't
make fun of me and I said I'm sorry I
think we've already done
I think Country Joe of country Jonah
fish called we did a Woodstock slappy he
was upset about some something we'd
parodied in there
I'm just killing time my contract says
to sing a song I made a rhyme that
doesn't sound like a party that sounds
like my son I think that um Steven
showed Martin Scorsese the the good
feathers arm and he really thought it
was funny
got a little close to Richard Lewis's
material in Noah's Ark cartoon so I
think Richard Lewis's manager said you
know could you try not to steal all of
his material next time and we said okay
look I don't know who you think I am and
I wish I could but I don't get on the
boat it was an homage Richard no no
nobody really we never heard from
anybody but maybe because of this they
will and they're gonna come after so
thanks a lot yes well I live to destroy
careers shoot me with that said sherry
as people may or may not know you were
the live-action reference for Ariel from
The Little Mermaid and Belle from Beauty
and the Beast and something I've noticed
is that there's a lot of Disney related
jokes in Animaniacs particularly in the
slappy the squirrel cartoons a junk
rotten out your brain no wonder you like
that bonkers joke i even recall one
where you blow up run over and smash
pluto the dark um bad memories are just
an easy target certainly not bad
memories no no no that was a lot of fun
doing the mermaid and Belle no uh
probably an easy target I mean slappy
though um made fun of not made fun of
but she knew everybody in show business
so everybody was fair game you know
hanna-barbera characters got slapped
around a lot by her too you think George
Jetson of course Steven Spielberg
produced both this show and Tiny Toons
which were both gigantic hits how
involved was he in the process because
from the look of things it looks like he
was a pretty damn good producer great I
mean he was involved in the fact that
you know he was making at the time I
think Jurassic Park and Schindler's List
and then whatever and then he'd be
faxing us notes on these little animated
scripts we draw
but mostly was interested in it being
funny and having a different look in a
field and everything else like that he
read every script what I remember about
him was that you would give him us you
know deliver us half our script maybe at
like two o'clock and by five o'clock he
would be calling with notes it was very
fast the turnaround with him was very
fast now um sometimes of course he'd be
busy really busy making a movie or
something I have a photo of him on the
said it shouldn't were just looking at
like a pinky LaBranche storyboard so I
was there maybe you know two months or
something and I had written a little bit
and I got a memo from Steven and I think
it said I really liked what you wrote
I think tears began well in my eyes and
I immediately called my wife at work and
I read her the memo and look was and
then I I think I ran throughout the
studio I got a flashlight and I let
everyone read the memos there was that
episode in freakazoid it's freakazoid
and then all of a sudden Wakko comes in
and then pink in the brain come in and
there's this whole exchange about what
shows Steven likes likes best well
Steven likes s best cuz we got a memo
and that's the memo I was talking about
if I'm not mistaken freakazoid
is Stephens favorite show we got our
Menna and I have the memo still it's in
up safe I don't let anyone look at it
but it was very very nice but I can't
complain I'm one of the few people in
the world that actually framed a Twitter
from Roger Ebert so yeah I do want you
if I said I didn't get excited about
stupid stuff like that - the beautiful
thing was when when people did come
after us or sensors or you know he he
basically would step in and ask others
to back off these guys are doing a good
job you know they're making the show I
want so it was it was fabulous people
ask me like they ask everyone wonder
kids what do you want to be when you
grow up and so I said I wanted to be
Steven Spielberg when I grown up my
parents did a really amazing
I got me a chance to meet him after this
big wrap party he just asked me what
were my favorite dinosaurs and what were
my favorite movies and I remember just
telling him these are the best dinosaurs
there are and and these are the best
movies and you should make movies with
these dinosaurs and so embarrassing but
it was really amazing that he listened
to me like I could see that on the
boards I was telling him like really
sunk in may you were a little kid
obviously when you did the voice of
Skippy squirrel did people recognize you
and if they did did you keep the low key
or did you try to soak up the attention
at first no one really did recognize me
that's the great part of being in an
animated series you can do all this hard
work you have this other secret identity
but I got interviewed for Sports
Illustrated for kids they're just going
to do a short interview and take a few
photos and turn into this like three or
four page spread about me as a voice
actor and after that the secret was out
and it was hard to like I wasn't a
celebrity though it was it was very
low-key but it was the worst kind of
celebrity for me at that age I was
turning 13 I was trying to appear very
masculine and suave to the ladies but
they all thought of me as this could be
Woodley fuzzy little squirrel and that
did not help me with the ladies for
quite a while
yeah it's hard being a squirrel now when
I watch these cartoons I really get a
feeling of the original Looney tune even
more than Tiny Toons which was literally
mimicking the original Looney Tunes but
something about Animaniacs just seemed
to have the same creative energy the
same need to hit both the adult audience
as well as the children audience did
they play a big part when writing this
and if not who did we weren't
consciously thinking about the old
Looney tune
you know saying let's do um this thing
like bugs did but um it certainly had to
be in that in in our consciousness
template I think we used originally
where were the Marx Brothers you know
that's sort of chaos that they
orchestrated in their films most of the
artists and you know certainly the
writers were very much influenced by the
Looney Tunes cartoons so maybe take Marx
Brothers and Looney Tunes and smash them
together I think you get Animaniacs they
were so masterful that it was something
to aspire to
I don't think they've been surpassed
certainly I to me I'm still in awe
whenever I see the old Warner Brothers
cartoons you know for me Daffy Duck is
pretty much the most perfect cartoon
character of all time that was a big in
influence I would know nothing about him
being influenced what sort of maybe I
learned from Looney Tunes was it's all
about character and if you have a great
character you can write a billion
episodes and I think that's what Looney
Tunes was it was was all about rather
than sort of necessarily this happens
then this happens then this happens the
Looney Tunes were like yeah Daffy's on a
cruise ship what can happen all the
cultural major events of our lives I
think everything we had gone through up
to the point where we're working on
Animaniacs it was fair game as far as we
were concerned any kind of inspired
silliness anything that was just fun for
funs sake would factor in you know Ernie
Kovacs that sort of weird stuff I was a
big fan of Monty Python and Jonathan
winters there are a few Abbott and
Costello movies that I Iverson had
memorized go ahead and tell me oh the
guy in first row the first fish who is
on first tell me the name of the band on
stage boom the name of the band who the
band on stage
one of my favorite memories are working
with Sherri stoner was doing the the
Woodstock episode with the what's the
name of the band on stage bit we spend a
lot of time together in the booth so we
could get the timing just right oh the
name of the group who the group on stage
Oh
man no the berries before me later and
then the Jerry Lewis thing for me was
just I was raised in Vegas I was eight
eight years old and and I would see
Jerry Lewis's name on the on the marquee
and I just thought he was the funniest
guy in the world Paul you're the
characters simply called mr. director
who you also do the voice for and he is
obviously a big influence of Jerry Lewis
you kids are gonna be in my movie who
are you just looking at the people
watching on TV people's what people's
how nice people in the TV I'm wondering
has he ever seen any of those cartoons I
you know what I have no idea
although when I was at Disney and I was
doing a show for them a while back I
tried to get Jerry Lewis to actually do
a bit on it and he said no and I don't
know whether it's because they said Oh
Paul rugs the guy that used to do I'm
not quite sure I actually remember there
is a tribute on Comedy Central for Jerry
Lewis and one of the clips they showed
was mr. director acting as Indiana Jones
so chances are he did see one of those
cartoons at some point okay good
good see animals likely knew who you
were and totally snuffed you after out
there there again um
sherry am i right that you were
originally brought into tiny toons to
mainly write for the best bunny
character yeah since that is the case
and you also invented slappy squirrel uh
what I really like about your writing is
uh we have another reviewer called a
nostalgia chick and she has a term
called the Smurfette principle and this
is about how a children show wants to be
gender-neutral by throwing in a token
chick pretty much and it's almost a
cliche the same men came right for women
but most of these female leads were
written as females first before they
were written as actual characters and I
can say growing up with the bb slappy
dot I always saw them as characters
first before I saw them as females and I
guess what I'm wondering is was there
ever a conscious effort to fight how
females were being written in anime
shows at that time or was this just how
you saw the characters I was never
um into girly girl characters when I was
young I remember liking Groucho Marx and
Harpo Marx
I liked Bugs Bunny the best out of the
Warner Brothers I liked gomez on the
Addams Family I always like the funny
one you know and so I was never into
princesses or any of that kind of thing
so it didn't really factor in for me to
write from that perspective for Babs or
any of the girl characters that I wrote
for because it wasn't how I looked at
the world and no one ever said all you
know let's bring in girl issues for Babs
or for dot or for anyone and I don't
think I would have first of all known in
fact I know I wouldn't have to do that
very well because I don't look at the
world that way I didn't try to make Babs
one of the fellas or I didn't try to
make dot one of the fellas certainly not
dot because um I mean there's a lot of
fun to be had with her playing up or her
girlish charms that she knows certainly
she thinks she knows what she's got no I
I wasn't conscious it was just the way I
sort of approached things let's talk
about the animation the animation was
always great but it did seem to have a
lot of variation the style would change
very often is sometimes it would be very
solid other times it would be very
bouncy
sometimes it was subtle sometimes it was
exaggerated how did that work what was
there different animation groups that
depend on the director like five
different different companies that that
would you know be farmed out a certain
short we were employing most of Asia at
the time we had Studios set up all over
Korea and Japan New Zealand at one point
the company called TMS there was a
company called Wang like a calm I think
in Japan was one of the top studios
whatever you said there always came back
looking great I could see that like
weighing had a style of drawing the
Warner's that was a little bit more
round II a calm was a little bit more
you know angular and stuff so yeah each
company had its own way of doing it and
then other Studios that would depend on
you know what they were what they were
up against you wouldn't always get their
best crew you know we'd get it back
and it would literally look like you
know yakko's eyes were melting off his
face and you'd be like oh we're in
trouble
certain ones came back so hashed you
know he couldn't save them and editing
yeah to try and make them into something
else there would be detailed storyboard
about exactly what would happen then the
timing person would come in and say okay
the gag from Yakko to go from this
position to this position has so many
frames these days there isn't as much
control you sort of just you know show
me a storyboard and you ship it over and
you Kissick a by him and hope nobody
looks really gross now let's talk about
one of the biggest factors on the show
the music
particularly the song we all know
richard stone did incredible scores and
incredible music but with every episode
there had to be a minimum of like two to
five songs in an episode many of them
using public domain music or satirizing
famous musicals how did writing songs
for the show work did the writers come
up with it did the musicians come up
with it was a sort of both we have done
a lot of music and improv and so we were
used to throwing it into you know into
sketches I think for me what what really
got me interested in including more
music was that it paid residuals when we
all found out we would get extra money
for writing songs we wrote a lot of
songs no for a while everything I wrote
was a light opera we had so many great
music composers people scoring the show
Richard stone and and the Bernstein's
sometimes we would throw them some
lyrics that they would also have to like
turn into little jingles everything you
would write the lyrics first and then it
was up to Richard stone to find a way to
make it sound like the original but not
so much that we get sued what can I say
I love the lyric and the musicians were
great they do exactly how to craft the
songs you know to stay within the legal
limits at the time anybody can do it
everybody did it everybody I can't think
of anybody that didn't write at least
some songs her legal guy we had one
legal guy who'd stop by once every two
years yes yeah yeah you guys could do it
fine you know you're staying off the you
know you're not getting us any letters
from lawyers so yeah they were they were
master
you know Richard stone and the our other
composers were masters of keeping it you
know just one side of a phone call if I
were a rich man
yeah the derivative is ever David David
um if I was a cottage on Kui Kui Kui
fettuccine cream sauce parmesan then we
had a guy like Randy Rogel who comes in
and he was working on Batman he said hey
Tom he walked up one day he said you
know I got this little song I wrote it a
year ago and it wasn't particularly
written for Animaniacs but they said I
think it would be cool for your show and
so he played it and everybody there
heard of her
yeah we should we should have Yakko we
got rob paulsen sing this and present
she really didn't have anything to do
with any other part of the show but it
was turned into yakko's world United
States Canada Mexico Panama Haiti
Jamaica Peru Republic Dominican Cuba
Carribean Greenland El Salvador to talk
about hits on internet I mean people
remember the show Libya then Argentina
and Ecuador Chile Brazil Costa Rica back
so once we had Rogel aboard
he said yeah Randy you can stay and then
Rob Paulsen who was so amazing is so so
amazing that he could deliver on the
song like that right I mean I've seen
him do it live I can't even believe it
he's amazing Costa Rica Belize Nicaragua
Bermuda Bahamas Tobago San Juan Paraguay
Uruguay Surinam and French Guiana
Barbados and Guam I actually tried
memorizing that song when I was a kid um
I don't recall doing very well I think I
get up to Canada but yeah it's a
obviously a very well-written song my
son took the AP History test and he said
kids in the class for singing the
president's song before the test so I
thought that was pretty funny don't
Tyler he like country bow and after him
competitive both enjoyed retailer like
do smoke his breath children whenever
you smoke then it became once he we saw
how door tom saw how successful he was
at the first one then it just became
well
Randy you know name all the planets
Orton you know name all the molecules
and title Makram saying but you know to
me so then we were literally we would
literally throw Randy a song idea like
how about like you know you ever been
stoned Randy I thought that he has ever
been stunned but you know when you kind
of plate the universe Randy you know
like like the whole universe could be on
the head of a pen
you know and so then he turned he wrote
yakko's universe which i think is a just
a beautiful song there's a hundred
billion galaxies that stretch across the
sky filled with constellations planets
moons and stars and still the universe
extends to a place that never ends which
is maybe just inside a little joke he
really took it to the next level
um about you know what a song for anime
and axes is gonna be an Indiana I think
she did a whole goodfeathers parody that
was all singing and stuff that was not
my I couldn't even oh that just made my
head hurt
with Lehman's her animal that was um
Deanna Oliver who did that and she was
very familiar with musical obviously
after the house diving out the charm
ready with a handshake and an open palm
vision exhibit Gavin Africare took a
little nibble from the barrier now how
on earth did you guys get Bernadette
Peters because that wasn't just a
walk-on cameo that was one of the main
characters using the opening credits and
she's pretty much a goddess a Broadway I
mean she was huge I think I honestly I
mean I think Steven Spielberg's name
carries a lot of class Andrei Romano and
Tom Ruger sorta had talked about and
said you know she would be great um boy
if only we could get her and then
everyone's like Oh Steven I know that
Andreea Romano was um putting it out
there too a lot of singers first and
somehow she got through to Bernadette
Peters people and she
and yes which was amazing I mean you
know the night the city overall meant we
were very lucky to get her we would have
to like sort of work around her schedule
she would come out once every month and
maybe we do two or three of her cartoons
then and so she would have to sing learn
and sing there are at least two songs
per per cartoon some of them are like
ballads and big big whopping songs there
is a plot in gay Paree they gonna train
you she's a performer she didn't want to
do these things like that I mean she
needed to like Honan and then what a
treat to actually go into a recording
session and actually get to hear her
sing in person cuz it's just astonishing
how shadows and out here there's a
promise I got here
liyan you know some of the performances
are almost like her almost touching
haunting this place Oh
Oh